let's see let's go next to let's go to
our caller from the 605 area code who's
calling today from 605 all right hi
David can you hear me yeah who's this
okay this is Daniel from South Dakota
hey Daniel what's going on so I support
a living you know $15 an hour wage but
some people like Andrew yang have been
speaking a lot about automation recently
and so I feel that like a legitimate
concern that some people have about a
living wage is that in order to save
money companies can just automate away
their jobs and you know they'll continue
to make a profit because of that and
that's already been happening like in
fast food I've noticed with automated
kiosks and stuff the question is is
acceleration of automation is that like
a legitimate concern at all when it
comes to a living wage if so is the EBI
an effective way to counter that so
listen I mean here so the answer is yes
Automation is a concern when we think
about living wages but it's not one that
is particularly exacerbated by the
winnaman wage being $15 versus 13 and
you know a lot of people like to point
to the fast food kiosks as you talked
about
because after minimum wages were
increased in certain places you saw
fast-food locations there deploy these
kiosks those kiosks have been in
development for a very long time it
doesn't just happen overnight that the
minimum wage goes up and then all of a
sudden these kiosks show up so the truth
is that those companies have been
planning on doing that for a very long
time and so I if your argument and it
sounds like at least part of your
argument is that a $15 minimum wage is
not going to solve the problem of
technological automation I agree with
you and this is one of the big sort of
missing elements that I'm glad Andrew
yang is talking about it and many many
other elected officials are not it's
that whether the minimum wage is 13 15
or 17 number one in lots of places
that's not a living wage or it's barely
a living wage that's a real issue and
number two the issue of automation as
well as machine learning and artificial
intelligence is going to make a lot of
that minimum wage discussion not
obsolete but it's going to make it less
applicable to a lot of jobs so I'm
completely with you it's not being
discussed in a serious manner
so would you support having Pro PPI and
a living wage
yeah I've listened I'm in support of all
of those things and for people who
criticize just a $15 minimum wage as
being merely a bandaid on our economic
system I agree right there's a bigger
problem that a band-aids not going to
fix ubi of $1,000 no matter you know I
disagreed with Andrew Yang's initial
version which was the thousand replaces
other benefits I think it should be
additive but that disagreement aside
that stuff only is on the fringes of the
broader economic problems or I guess I
would call them deeper economic problems
that we have to solve alright thank you
appreciate the phone call thank you very
much great great to hear from you